he hablado ya múltiples veces de lo que
significa esta mayúscula que es la
energía interna de un sistema y
realmente es todo lo que está aventado
ahí verdad la energía cinética de las
moléculas la energía potencial si las
moléculas están vibrando tienen la
energía química de los enlaces la
energía potencial de los electrones
cuando quieren llegar a cierto lugar
pero bueno para fines de lo que vamos a
hacer que es bastante introductorio para
química o física o incluso termodinámica
es vamos a suponer que estamos hablando
de un gas ideal ok y más aún que es un
gas ideal mono atómico es decir que sólo
tengo un tipo de átomo el entonces todo
lo que está en mis sistemas son átomos
individuales y en ese caso la única
energía en el sistema es la energía
cinética de cada una de esas partículas
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
ponerle un poco matemático quizás pero
quiero llegar a relacionar cuánta
energía interna hay en un sistema dada
su presión su volumen o su temperatura
así que queremos relacionar presión
volumen y temperatura
la energía interna todos los vídeos que
hemos hecho hasta ahorita hemos dicho
cuál es el cambio la energía interna y
quiero relacionar eso con el calor y
ponerlo o para obtener el trabajo hecho
por o para el sistema pero ahorita vamos
a vamos vamos a determinar cuánta
energía interna tiene un sistema y me
voy a voy a voy a simplificar muchísimo
este experimento mental digamos
y yo creo que van a encontrarlo bastante
bien y satisfactorio pero bueno digamos
que dibujo bueno digamos que tengo un
cubo ok creo que creo que ya he hecho
esta demostración en algún otro vídeo
pero bueno no está nunca además tenerlo
en esta lista de termodinámica así que
digamos que mi sistema está en este cubo
y digamos que sus dimensiones del cubo
son x en cada una de las direcciones
verdad entonces es x de alto x de ancho
y x de profundo así que su volumen su
volumen por supuesto es x al cubo
digamos que tengo n n partículas en
mayúscula si usamos en minúscula eso lo
dejamos para moles pero bueno luego lo
veremos entonces tengo n partículas y
todos están haciendo pues lo que su
voluntad les dice sale entonces vamos a
hacer una gran simplificación pero en
este sistema cada partícula tiene que
estar rebotando en cada una de las
direcciones en todas las posibles
direcciones y eso es digamos si se choca
con alguna
algún muro rebota de forma elástica es
un choque elástico verdad entonces para
fines de esta simple simplificación
vamos a
hacer una suposición voy a suponer que
un tercio de todas las partículas
están yéndose en la dirección paralela a
cada uno de los ejes digamos que un
tercio de las partículas se van en esta
dirección
yo creo que puedo decirle de izquierda a
derecha otro tercio de las partículas va
arriba y abajo aquí así arriba y abajo
y otro tercio de las partículas van
hacia adelante y hacia atrás
y sabemos que esto no es en realidad
cierto pero hacen nuestra matemática más
simple y de hecho si hiciéramos la
mecánica estadística del problema de
todas estas partículas podríamos ver que
llegamos a este resultado pero bueno con
esto dicho ya no vamos a hacer más este
súper simplificaciones excepto que vamos
a hacer cambios infinitesimalmente
pequeños y vamos a hablar después de
este tipo de cosas pero en este sistema
debido al movimiento se generará presión
con esto dicho vamos a estudiar ahora si
el sistema
ok entonces digamos que tengo una vista
frontal de el sistema vamos a estudiar
una única partícula y voy a hacerlo con
verde no con café está bien con café
entonces esta partícula tiene cierta
masa y cierta velocidad verdad se mueve
a la derecha y a la izquierda y esta es
una de esas partículas de las n que
tengo en el sistema ahora tengo
curiosidad de cuánta presión ejerce esta
partícula en este muro de aquí
en este muro de aquí sabemos lo que lo
que vale el área de este mundo verdad el
área de este muro es x por x que es x
cuadrada ok
este es el área cuánta fuerza ejerce la
partícula en el muro digamos si está
yéndose a la derecha y a la izquierda
justo así la fuerza ejercida cuando
cambia su momento su momento voy a hacer
digamos las cuentas porque la fuerza es
igual a la masa por la aceleración
verdad ahora sabemos que la aceleración
es la mã es el cambio en la velocidad es
decir también la velocidad sobre el
cambio en el tiempo verdad simplemente
sustituir y por supuesto esto lo podemos
escribir metiendo la constante dentro
esto simplemente es el delta o el cambio
en la masa por la velocidad
y del tate y ese es simplemente el
momento verdad así que esto es igual al
cambio en el momento respecto al tiempo
verdad y esa es otra forma de escribir
la fuerza así que cuál es eso para esta
partícula bueno está rebotando en esta
dirección tiene algún momento digamos
mb y está rebotando en este muro así y
rebota en sentido contrario bueno si
tenemos un choque elástico entonces
rebota con la misma velocidad verdad no
se pierde calor no se pierde nada en de
energía entonces el nuevo momento va a
ser menos
mb también solo ha cambiado la dirección
ahora sí sí si queremos ver cuál es el
cambio en el momento baja entonces
tenemos que restar el el momento final
ajá digamos el cambio en el momento es
el momento final
la diferencia verdad es el momento final
menos el momento inicial que es 2 mb
ahora eso no nos da la fuerza aún hay
que dividir esto esto entre el cambio en
el tiempo del tate
esto por unidad de tiempo así que que
tan frecuentemente ocurre esto bueno lo
que va a ocurrir aquí es que cada vez
que yo choco con esta pared la partícula
se rebota en la misma dirección pero en
sentido contrario verdad que hay
entonces que tan frecuentemente esto va
a ocurrir bueno eso depende de qué tan
largo es el intervalo que tenemos entre
las colisiones verdad con el muro bueno
la partícula viajando tiene una
distancia x verdad hacia la derecha ya
la izquierda déjenme hacerlo con otro
color entonces esta distancia de aquí es
x lo que va a hacer es viajar x hasta la
izquierda y luego regresa con otra
distancia x es decir viajo 12 x ziketan
que tanto es esto bueno vamos a ver del
tate es el cambio en el tiempo el tiempo
que tarda en regresar al mismo punto
después de varios choques es la
distancia que es 2x
y bueno eso va a ser dividido entre la
tasa verdad la velocidad entonces esta
es nuestra noción básica de la velocidad
nada más que despejando el tiempo y
entonces la distancia es 2x dividida por
cuál es nuestra tasa bueno es la
velocidad verdad entonces dividimos
entre b
ahí lo tienen entonces está del tate no
es otra cosa más que esta expresión
ahora nuestro cambio en el momento por
unidad de tiempo el cambio de momento
por unidad de tiempo es igual a 2 2 mb
que es el momento incidente digamos
porque el choque el choque tiene un un
es un choque elástico y regresa con la
misma dirección pero en sentido
contrario y entonces al colisionar con
este muro aquí hay que dividir entre la
velocidad que es 2x sobre b que haciendo
las operaciones tenemos 2 mb por b que
es y esto dividimos entre 2x verdad y
esto simplemente es igual a estas dos se
cancelan y tenemos m de cuadrada sobre x
muy interesante estamos llegando a un
lugar bastante interesante a lo mejor
tienes intuición para checar a dónde
vamos a ir llegando más o menos pero
esta es la fuerza que aplicamos por una
partícula verdad esta fuerza es solo de
una partícula en este muro
la fuerza de una partícula y ahora cuál
era el área bueno saquemos con la
presión la presión
la presión
es igual lo escribí acá arriba la
presión es igual a la fuerza entre el
área es decir fuerza por unidad de área
verdad así que si esta es la fuerza de
la partícula esto es m de cuadrada sobre
x y esto lo dividimos entre el área del
muro ahora cuál era el área del muro
bueno era x cuadrada verdad si cada uno
bueno este muro en realidad es
bidimensional y es un muro de un cubo y
eso es tiene un área de x cuadrada y
esto que es igual esto es igual a m p
cuadrada sobre sobre x al cubo verdad
simplemente multiplicamos estos dos 2
estas dos expresiones y eso nos da x al
cubo ahora lo que tenemos es algo muy
interesante la presión ejercida por una
partícula digamos vamos a llamarle la
presión
vamos a llamarle de particular ajá es
igual a mb cuadrada m de cuadrada sobre
x al cubo pero que es x al cubo pues ese
es el volumen de nuestro contenedor ok
entonces es sobre el volumen vamos a
ponerlo como de grande d mayúscula así
que vamos a ver si podemos relacionar
esto con algo más eso significa que la
presión ejercida por una partícula ok
bueno déjenme saltarme un paso cuál es
la previa y bueno si ésta es una
partícula que choca con un muro
ahora si consideramos las n partículas
todas las partículas que fracción de
ellas van a estar rebotando en este muro
ok y van a hacer lo mismo que esta
partícula entonces tenemos un tercio de
todas las partículas haciendo lo mismo
que esta particular que
verifique verdad entonces tenemos en
total n entre tres partículas chocando
de esta forma entonces esta es la
presión por cada partícula si quiero
tomar toda la presión de todas las
partículas entonces la presión total en
este muro va a ser n entre 3
multiplicado por la presión de cada una
verdad entonces si queremos la total la
presión total de en este muro la presión
simplemente lo voy a poner presión entre
muro por el muro digamos es m de
cuadrada sobre b qué es lo que la
presión que ejerce una partícula por
todas las partículas que tenemos
entonces esto es por n entre 3 verdad
entre 3 son el número de partículas que
están rebotando en esa dirección así que
la presión total en este muro es igual a
md cuadrada entre el volumen por n entre
3 vamos a ver si podemos manipular un
poco las cosas si multiplicamos ambos
lados por digamos
por si multiplicamos ambos lados por 3
por 3 3 b vamos a poner 3 b entonces
tenemos que por b y multiplicamos por b
es igual a md cuadrada por n muy bien
ahí tenemos verdad entonces si dividimos
ambos lados por n entonces vamos a tener
que 3 p b
centre déjenme déjenme de olviden esto
último vamos a dividir mejor ambos lados
de esta igualdad por 2 entonces
dividimos entre 2 y que nos queda del
lado izquierdo el lado izquierdo vamos a
tener tres medios de pep por b iguala y
esto es muy interesante verdad en el
número de moléculas por mb cuadrada
entre 2
recuerden solo dividir la ecuación aquí
por 2 y esto lo hice por una particular
razón quienes m de cuadra entre 2 esto
es la energía cinética de esta pequeña
partícula que con la que empezamos
verdad es la fórmula de la energía
cinética y es igual a m p cuadrada sobre
ok entonces esta es la energía cinética
de una partícula esta es la energía
cinética de una partícula
ahora lo estamos multiplicando por el
número de partículas que hay que son n
entonces esto nos da simplemente la
energía cinética de todas las partículas
ok y supuse que todas las partículas se
mueven a la misma velocidad en una
situación real podrían tener diferentes
velocidades pero bueno era una de
nuestras suposiciones iniciales para
simplificar todo esto entonces si
multiplicamos la energía cinética por el
número de partículas es la energía
cinética del sistema del sistema
y ya casi estamos ahí de hecho ya
estamos ahí porque hemos dicho que la
energía cinética del sistema es igual a
tres medios de la presión por por el
volumen ahora cuál es la energía
cinética del sistema es la energía
interna verdad porque dijimos que la
energía del sistema era solo la energía
cinética porque era un gas ideal mono
atómico y demás sale entonces podremos
decir que la energía interna del sistema
es igual a es igual a
igual a tres medios por la presión por
el volumen y podrías decir oye tú lo
hiciste para una la presión sobre un
lado del cubo verdad y eso en realidad
no importa porque la presión en
cualquier pared del cubo es la misma
entonces esencialmente estamos
encontrando lo mismo en cada pared del
sistema y bueno así podemos concluir
esto ahora que más sabemos que la
presión por el volumen es igual la nrc
verdad donde n es el número de moles r
es la constante
en es la constante del gas ideal y t es
la temperatura en grados kelvin así que
si hacemos esto si sustituimos tenemos
tres medios por el número de moles la
constante del gas ideal y por la
temperatura ahora he hecho bastante
trabajo esto es muy matemático pero
estos resultantes son estos resultados
son muy interesantes porque tenemos una
relación entre la presión y el volumen
con la energía interna y también una
relación entre la energía interna que es
la energía cinética con la temperatura
ok y el número de moléculas que tengo
entonces aquí tenemos la energía interna
y ahí hay un par de claves para poder
ver esto si la temperatura no cambia en
una situación ideal es decir del tate es
igual a cero entonces él como el número
de partículas y la constante no cambian
entonces la que el cambio en la energía
interna es cero
y si sabemos que hay algún cambio en la
energía interna vamos a usar esto en
demostraciones próximas esto es igual a
tres medios
nr y lo único que puede cambiar la
temperatura verdad entonces cambio en la
temperatura o también podríamos
escribirlo como que es tres medios por
el cambio en la presión por el volumen
no sabemos que sea esto ni si cambia
sólo una o ambas pero bueno esto es un
poco matemático está bien espero que
esto les dé mucho más sentido lo que
realmente es la suma de la energía
cinética y solo quiero dejar claro que
estas variables macro estos macro
estados
se relacionan con la energía en el
próximo vídeo vamos a usar estos
resultados o al menos espero ya no se
compliquen mucho con estas cuentas